keely is next on the Dave Ramsey show
from California hi Akili how are you I'm
doing well fairing yourself better than
I deserve
what's up I just wanted to get your
advice on something real quick um
basically just to give you a back story
I'm 22 years old I am I work part-time
at a retail store I'm a 16 bucks an hour
24 on Sundays I am one class away from
transferring to a university and I still
live at home my parents but at home our
financial situation not the greatest
right now or unfortunately like one
house payment away from possibly losing
our house and I'm desperately in need of
a car and it's just kind of a mess right
now I mean is this your home where your
parents on how this is my parents home
oh so that's not your responsibility
okay yes um I've just been very you know
burned-out on my job and just everything
you know everything I've been going
through analysis down I feel like every
day you know I got my brains on
autopilot it's like I have no purpose
and for the longest time I've been
wanting to go on this mission trip um
it's called why when you through the
mission it's kind of a global you know
missionary Christian missionary thing
yeah I'm very familiar well I've been
trying to uh you know I I'm gonna have
the money to go but it's basically all
that I have and I had a very a couple of
days ago I had a very vivid dream you
know just a real dream that I was there
and you know I felt like I was supposed
to be there but you know if I if I pay
for this thing is literally gonna be all
that I have and I'm not sure it know
every time I think about not going I
feel this just great way to desire the
army that you know if I don't go I'm
gonna be stuck here forever and you know
just I just really need to find my
purpose and so my question basically is
do you think that I should you know
spend all that I have to go on this trip
and trust God and see what happens too
deep and she just and I go this is the
only time I'm ever going to really uh
have the opportunity because that you
know
opportunity in transferring to
University you know will give me some
free time and so I just wanted to you
know get your thoughts on that yeah I
would probably go ym is a very diverse
organization and what that means is
there's the the DTS are all disconnected
and so there's a vast array of
experiences that you could have in Y
William so it's not all Y om is not the
same so so I can't say but by and large
I've known a bunch of people that have
been involved with ym for 40 years and
have had by and large good experiences
and it's a godly endeavor and and I
think it's not a bad thing for you to do
at all I do think you're making some
statements that are ridiculous okay you
know I'm never gonna get to serve God
and if I don't go do this I'm I've
missed god that's just crazy okay this
is just a moment in time you've got the
money
it's a transitionary time in your life
you're young you're free you're going to
trust God with faith to work thing you
work things out when you get back but
you're burned out at a sixteen dollar an
hour job so get a different one I mean
you don't want to go on the mission
field to escape your job that's not good
right okay you're supposed to go on the
mission field to serve not to be served
this is not rehab it's mission work and
so it's not for your benefit so it's not
to help you with your burnout it's not
to help you with you you know you're
stressed out it's not to help you with
any of that you don't go on the mission
field to escape a bad life that's a bad
idea it's not spiritually healthy either
and your dramatizing this is if there's
no other way you're ever going to get to
do anything in the service of the Lord
the rest of your life I never went to
why women have served got a whole bunch
of different ways and and at different
times he's told me clearly what to do
and other times it was last night's
pizza and I just thought it was God you
know so you're gonna have all of that so
don't
this is not so fatalistic that if you
miss it one time at 22 years old that
you're somehow unplugged from the Holy
Spirit for the rest of your life
so don't go because you're needy that's
not good for the people you're going to
serve nor is it nor it should missions
be an escape mechanism so don't go
because you're burn out you're needy
don't go because you feel trapped none
of that's good okay and don't
overdramatize this as if you're stuck
forever in this job because you didn't
go to why why and God told you to you
think he's not gonna forgive you for not
going if you don't go you'll get another
job you change your life you move do
something else you know so let's not put
so much drama on our spirituality and
it'll it'll help you in your walk with
this whole thing so um but all of that
said I love your heart and and and you
know you're a good man and you're
thinking this and you're seeking to hear
God's voice and I want you to do that
and I want you to go I think you ought
to go on the trip but when you come home
dude you need to grab this thing called
life by the horns and get control of it
because right now it's whipping your
butt alright so when you come home you
come home with big broad square
shoulders in the spiritual realm and
strengthened and ready to get back after
it and I'm not a victim I'm not stuck in
this bad job I'm not stuck in this
situation because my family can't
control money you're not stuck God's a
big God and you can do all things
through Christ who strengthens you right
yes there so when you come you know I
want this to be like spiritual boot camp
for you while you're gone I want you to
come home Superman yes there get away
from the Kryptonite okay so I think you
ought to go but just just you know just
always remember don't don't run to the
mission field as an escape mechanism too
many times people that are believers do
that and it makes really bad
missionaries and really bad Christians
so go in with strength but I think you
can do that and I think God can give you
that strength so part of that's you know
part of your discussion I really loved
part of it I didn't
and I've addressed it so all of that
said if I was your dad and you're asking
me I would tell you to go and when you
get home you'll be broke and you'll be
ready to start life fresh and that's
cool and you can make it and God will
work your you know you'll see some
wonderful faith things happen there I
always do around awhile and process it's
part of the way why when works is you're
right on the edge of everything and so
you God just has to show up and you get
to see him work with his hands on so all
of that hey you're good man
you do a good job out there for the Lord
and you come back and live this next
chapter of your life in strength and in
abundance right now I love it good to
talk to you sir